hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to similacra 2. you
know what i love about this it's got
like the charm of a full motion video
game while still being set in modern era
i really hope that there's another ad
dead of night that comes out because i
just really enjoyed that one hello we've
got to get back to work i hope i don't
see anything strange is that really the
only thing i have can i not talk to
these people
can i not give them
a hey what's up oh we don't see anything
strange again what are you talking about
your vision of mine i forgot to ask you
what did you see i didn't tell you about
a vision
i saw her unlocking alive looking in
when i opened the case file she was
looking at me i saw her turn around
i saw her alive
looking at photo of her friends must be
an empathic electroplasm imprint a
strong pup yeah that transferred to the
yeah
are you making this up
these are legitimate and recorded
scientific observations they don't teach
you kids anything useful these days once
we're done with this i'm going to
properly school you so you can survive
working for dupe anyway these visions
are mostly harmless thanks for the
report
mostly
well we never found out what happened to
those who went missing or died after
experiencing these things
yeah definitely wasn't related their
deaths or whatever like that
it's fine don't worry about that
why did it
are you about to give me a strange
occurrence
are you
am i
am i about to get a strange occurrence
maya
maya
oh i have many things find a way to
contact pumped up clicks try to contact
allurin liaison to verify arya's
sponsorship find concrete evidence to
verify mina's tragic story investigate
who was the most likely to have accepted
the ripple man's deal
right
okay so it was erica simmons it was in
august but i don't know what the
district was
why do i not know that
springwood
spring wood one word springwood one word
spring wood got it springwood springwood
nailed it spring
wood
in august
document found there it is national
police catalog okay
accident report august 8 2012 hit and
run
june kovac the driver okay that's
important june kovac erica simmons
mina de silva pedestrian ah interesting
okay so erica simmons was driving
unknown driver hit unknown driver oh was
june kovac the person in the car with
erica it was about 7 36 p.m and we were
stopped at the red light intersection at
springwood the light had just turned
green and we were attempting to cross
that's when a man in a black sedan
coming from saint martin's road ran the
light and slammed into the passenger
side of our car hitting erika simmons it
sped off before we realized what was
happening a few drivers from the other
car stopped to help and they stayed with
us until the ambulance arrived but no
one remembers the plate number of the
car that hit us the collision inflicted
grievous injuries upon the front
passenger erika simmons emergency
services state that she was dead moments
before they arrived at the scene the
driver june kovac suffered light trauma
they were interviewed before being
escorted to the hospital for treatment
no traffic cameras were located at the
accident site but a witness mina da
silva was able to corroborate june
kovac's version of the events as of now
no new information is known about the
hidden run vehicle
interesting okay argentine souza
why have i heard that name before souza
inventor of the sousaphone i remember
that okay let me try calling june kovac
hi june hey june here if you're
listening to this that means i can't
come to the phone i will text you soon
oh god hi
this is mina
i can't take your call right now but
i'll be in touch when i'm able to
shush
new video synced okay i have a chat from
june
see it's the police i'm looking into
your accident again maybe it might help
i don't know
what really
this is so sudden
you closed the investigation years ago
why now again a murder case is connected
to your accident
oh my god
a murder is it the hit and runner did
they kill someone again maybe my
therapist told me to let it go but i
knew deep down i was holding onto it for
a reason
let's see it's about your other witness
the other witness
i'm sorry i don't know who you're
talking about
it was just me and erica
no wait
there was someone else that girl mina
aha
she was the one who called the ambulance
[Music]
waste my time
look at him out there staring at me
did you just butt dial me
yeah yeah yeah
whatever just do your job
this is uh what uh
huh
i
okay thank you she said erica was her
best friend
what
why would she say that
seriously i don't understand any of this
can you please just be straightforward
you're not gonna like what she's been
claiming online
i don't know why i feel the name to burn
these
people's whole world but i mean this is
just like a straight-up lie what a lying
snake who gave her the right she's
talking about the accident
using erica's name is her story true
i mean it's a true event
but i am erica's best friend not her she
just stole my story passing off a
tragedy as her own why would someone do
that
for likes i mean i've heard of people
presenting themselves as the hero but as
the victim that is just
pathetic any way for me to verify this
why don't you believe me
a lot of lies going along those bloody
chimera stars are just looking for drama
in their empty boring lives putting
themselves on a pedestal while using
pain to fish for pity likes why not just
snap a selfie with erica's corpse you
[ __ ] i need concrete evidence to prove
that
still on proof
fine
local star swimmer killed in hit and run
our local paper covered the accident
using a real death to tell a fake story
that's pure evil i'm sorry i'm not in
the mood you got we need right i'm need
to be alone
oh all officers who handled case file
g31298 please report to the detective's
office thank you
uh maybe i will maybe i won't okay so
that whoa there's a lot of different
things happening all at once here
okay chimera
i'm just a girl sitting with my guitar
asking you to keep rocking on
hmm
where was that was it jabber
ah interesting
june is fierce and mean it for
exploiting someone else's personal grief
for her own benefit i feel like this
isn't exactly permanent pertinent to my
investigation however
it uh probably is
only
appropriate yep currently ruining
someone's career but you know they
didn't do themselves
oh god
oh my god
oh my god
is she breathing don't
we don't check up house
[Music]
evil
monster thing what what demon i don't
know
this is like a
gas leak it's a castle yeah
stop okay it's bad enough just shut up
rex
stop
okay
we can't just stay here
and and not do anything okay we have to
just figure
we should just figure this out and just
keep calm and
yes yeah yeah we we we don't yeah one we
have to we have to get one more tickets
we need to get out of here i mean that's
another option
we have to figure this out
okay
okay somehow we have to figure this out
maya was telling the truth oh my
she was right
she was right it's not gonna stop
and that means that means
that one of us
[Music]
is the murderer
made the deal
oh
but who did it who could have done it
but it'd probably not mean if mina is
doing the accusing i don't think rex
would have been the one to do it i mean
rex is like it definitely could happen
and i would not doubt it but arya i
think had
more reason what
oh
i have to ask you about this
why are you triggering me with this what
the heck
i didn't know they did such a big report
your story about erica was a lie no no
no this story's real it's just someone
else's
okay i didn't know her personally
but it really did affect me okay i
witnessed someone dying
why did you may i'm finding it hard to
trust you after this we could have been
friends if i knew her for like longer
that's the only part i made up i'm sorry
okay i had to
did you though did you really though
people don't want to just listen to your
music the way that they want the whole
package the way you look and act has to
match
let's see so it's just branding you're
benefiting from other people's grief oh
goodness did i put a sad frowny cloud on
that well
i'm expressing their grief for them
there's a different you totally don't
get it
people think it's so easy to get
discovered but there's like so many
musicians out there to be authentic you
have to change your reality a little i
could reach out with my music before but
now everyone's listening to me i just
want people to listen
whoa what the [ __ ] is that a trauma was
real for someone i know that okay
i was just trying to help i think this
sadie
lightning is like i'm going down a meeny
path just people like the rockstar mina
much more than the real me when the
criticism started i exaggerated even
more you're just using self-pity for
attention
you sound like aryan rex
when the deal thingy came up i was
already uncomfortable even thinking of
taking another easy way out plus the
sacrifice thing was totally weird so i
ignored it
oh god she helped you grow as a person
yes that's why i trusted her as my
manager
i should have believed maya the first
time she mentioned all this it was it
was just like too weird
by the time i understood it was too late
you can stop it from happening again
sunshiny
how i couldn't even help maya
it all happened so fast and we were all
so useless because we couldn't process
anything that was going on and then she
was gone i don't know what to think or
do anymore
you must know
something you must
oh my god i'm so confused right now
and i'm like the real idiot for going
along with arya and rex
they're the worst
of course one of them would have done
this to poor maya maybe even together
why would
arya take the deal
i know she's been losing jobs
i didn't dare ask her about it she gets
really defensive sometimes you know
but anyway she was out of cash and
pretty desperate for work okay why was
she losing jobs
cause like people found she was faking
stuff on her camera and her clients
weren't super not happy about it after
we got the deal thingy
she started getting all the big brands
on her side like even a modeling gig
no one wanted to give her work and
suddenly she's hot stuff again you think
she'd sacrifice maya just for that
maybe
maybe
i've always been a bit scared of arya
she's really smart and that's why she's
super good at manipulating people i
think maya finally saw through that and
arya felt threatened
could rex have taken the deal instead
rex is a total user
he got away with conning like so many
people
but his fans just believe everything he
says
it's really weird like i don't know i
don't think that's normal how did he con
people
like you know he tried to get me to
intern for him for free
so many people have tried to complain
about his weird business maya said she
was sick of hearing him rant about it
but now it's like all those complaints
went away
only the ripple man can make that happen
isn't it extreme to sacrifice maya for
this
um rex thinks everything's one big game
and he just plays people he sees people
like us like they're his pawns or prawns
or something
pawns
i think you're right
oh my god i'm right
i knew he was that selfish
whoa
there's a video i got this when i was
stupid enough to do free work for him
i want to grow my business by growing
each and every one of you
if you sign up as a regular subscriber
you'll get
fans and likes straight out of the back
what we want you to do then is you'll
start recruiting people and for everyone
you recruit you get a slice of their
fees
and even more likes
if you make it to platinum level
you will have an army of people working
for you getting your businesses likes
promoting what you're doing
if you hustle smart you can make it all
the way to the top of the pyramid uh top
of the food chain food chain
top of the food chain
guys this this right here this is
innovation this is how little guys like
us we're going to disrupt the entire
industry are you with me
yeah
this is it
yeah
[Applause]
yeah
yeah it's a ponzi scheme it's a
pyramid's game well
alvin had too much money in the bank
too much i don't get it myself but like
loads of people were super angry with
him about this i'll see what he has to
say
[Music]
one okay i'm writing this down
okay
five five five seven five oh two three
five nine rex rexy baby
geez what now
i swear to god i'm going to find out
what you look like and if i ever see
your face in person do you want to see
my face now
very funny you almost sounded like maya
do you want to see it
my face
my face jesus
goodbye right whoa hey that's a nice
face you got there was that rex's face
as
hi maya
[Laughter]
give me the bad news
oh the higher ups know about our
investigation
since i violated numerous protocols and
laws they're considering misconduct
charges against me worse they're
threatening to dissolve dupe and destroy
all my research on the simulacra
who are the higher-ups
if i told you i would have to kill you
literally there's a silver lining
they're willing to drop everything if we
nail this case
we need the culprit who took the deal
and any images or footage proving the
existence of the ripple man
so where are we on this well i'll get
back to you on that one i'll i'll get
back to you on that one see you in a bit
i seem to have some issues
[Music]
okay um good yoga
grade yoga actually incredible yoga
[Music]
that's some good yoga best yoga i've
ever seen
hi my uh
wow
i love my car you know how much i love
my car
not so much
[Music]
um
[Music]
daily basis imma pull the trigger flex
start your trip in daily basis imma
fight the system i show you how to live
outside the social conventions i try to
see the humor in the worsted situation
the crowd please your attention sealer
i'm sharp tooth i stomp through i'm a
damage dealer i rock you talk you into
submission mission impromptu
party send everyone to the bathroom
to advance your prehistoric hawaii is
the question and the answer is to
correct but new jams are too advanced
you prehistoric co-op is the question
that the answer is rhetoric who you
messing with
[Music]
is this the vision that i got when uh
maya was calling rex
was it just
i feel like it
was like
who you playing with who you messing
with who you playing with it's kind of
catchy you know i'm not going to lie
it's kind of catchy who you messing with
who you playing with
[Music]
i like his stacks of 10 bills i think
it's very impressive wow look at that
okay who your new song downloaded yeah
hell yeah baby
that's the good [ __ ] right there that's
the good [ __ ]
okay
since tyrannosaurus i'm the best since
tyrannosaurus well this is a much better
version of the song than what i just
heard okay whatever
all right um what was i doing hello i
feel so naive
i didn't think rex would go this far
but i'm not really surprised
he's always bragging about how he's
smarter than everyone else
he thinks it's okay to just mess up
people's lives just because he knows how
to get away with it
not this time
we're gonna get him
we
isn't talking his way out of this
what do you what do you what do you mean
what are you um uh what was that all
about
so where are we on this
rex could be the one mina could be the
one why don't i have any evidence on
arya being the one possibly
why don't i have any evidence about that
i feel like i should have some evidence
about that
ah
hi
right i can send an email can't i
can't i uh there's gotta be some way
wasn't there a website yes be our muse
contact 1-800
whoa
welcome to the allurin hotline be true
be you be alluring press three to ask
about our muse program if you wish to
follow up on your application as our
muse please press one want to be our
muse
are you you enough to be a part of us
hunt us down at our pop-up stores and
get your applications filled
if you have already applied and want to
get in touch with your talent liaison
please dial the four-digit extension
number after the beat
okay so i need to find a four digit
extension number that's what i gotta
find
ah i didn't wasn't there there was like
uh an email
that
eight seven one four eight seven one
four okay got it
thank you your liaison is
rachel
hi
hi rachel
however your call cannot be connected as
she's not at her desk at this moment she
is informed of your call and will get
back to you as soon as possible have a
nice day okay i will thank you allurin
all right that's one objective down kind
of
i'm sure they'll give me a call when
it's whoa hi
hello this is what is that all about be
true be you be alluring who is this i'm
an officer investigating one of
uh
one of your influencers i would like to
follow up on my
i'm an officer
what oh my god an investigation you bet
just hold up for a minute here
maybe i shouldn't have
i got a big campaign planned out and i
can't have any of my muses leaking any
controversial stuff can we just settle
things privately over here let's see i'm
afraid this is a very serious matter
please this cannot be public
okay if you want dirt on our influencers
i'll tell you anything you want let's be
the first to announce it
who do you want to know about
see uh
i want you to know what you think of
arya park
okay give me a second
that name sounds familiar
she's not one of ours
she applied but didn't get through here
then why did she announce it on chimera
she's faking it sometimes our rejects do
this
but as long as they don't get us into
trouble we're pretty okay with it i mean
it's no big deal right
can we just quietly resolve this and not
make it public
uh
it's not my problem that she used your
brand for this that's not my problem
can you just stop right there
okay why don't i make this easier for
all of us
here was going to release this anyway so
here it is
ah interesting
whoopsies
i see now that arya being extremely
selfish because of her recklessness
she's dragging our brain down we cannot
have that i'm going to push this out
right now
all right
honestly arya you're loud obnoxious
overall but faking this ambassador thing
is the last straw
[Music]
you can't just do that this conclusively
disproves arya's relationship with us so
you don't have to drag
the right to drag us into this this will
suffice thank you for your cooperation
you can't hear me but i'm dusting my
hands off right now
if you have any more issues take it with
our legal department chaosey we heard
your feedback and what we're now
denouncing all of our phonely muses
starting with
ah interesting the dirt comes out or you
would never sink that low
wow
wow wow
wow
wow they had that primed and ready to go
five seconds ago okey dokey then
okay so that's another step gym security
maya at her gym
locker
what does that even mean
i don't even know what that means all
right inform murillo of your findings
confront rex about his
okay confront whoa
sorry
hey um
aria can i please confront arya could i
confront arya okay i must need to talk
to this dude
let's see mina could be the one could be
so she's making up stories for some
sympathy huh
i suspect someone's so insecure and
needy might have a lot of uses for that
deal i sort of feel bad for even if she
sacrificed maya
one of these kids ended a life for a
little bit of fame so save your sympathy
but they don't deserve it
if we make a mistake and screw the case
up no ones will know the truth about the
simula
and i'll go back to being treated like a
fool
i'll keep on talking to him
don't get sidetracked
two more left to talk to
i'll be in touch
yeah sure you will buddy sure you will
i'm sure you will i couldn't stop
feeling like a disappointment drm gave
me hope for a new career on social media
offered two full
full rides to two lives things were
great until my mom passed away life is
funny creeping way up on you my dad was
supportive oh
detective marilla has been placed under
observation all junior officers please
get confirmation from your direct
supervisor before executing any orders
[Applause]
field team delta you are placed under
special assignment please report back to
hq for immediate briefing why
what do you mean
what does that mean what
is anyway i guess it's time to confront
people
um
yeah
i have to ask you about this
what the heck is this
you lied about being their ambassador
god damn it
fine i admit it i faked my brand
sponsorship oh no allurin published it i
am so screwed what do you have against
me
you're just as bad as those so-called
fans who just follow me to troll and put
me down
that's why you want them gone
of course i want them gone
i can't go anywhere without these haters
lurking around i needed that to learn
deal to boost my ratings okay
you have to show that you're successful
to get jobs and perception trumps real
this every time plus it learns a big
company i didn't think they'd bother
checking someone like me
oh
things are gonna get worse for you
that too faced
listen i was desperate and i made a
stupid mistake
sometimes i feel pressure to act like my
life is more exciting than that it is
okay but i can and intend to fix my in
on my own terms i never needed the
ripple man's deal ignore the video i'm
opening it i'm opening it
[Applause]
i am
loving this
looking good chief
just get your ass back to work of course
of course you got it you got it pal
you're a fighter when things get hard
you are a fighter when things get hard
i don't appreciate you digging into my
personal life
but if it helps me make my case go right
ahead will you believe me now i didn't
take the ripple man's deal i didn't kill
maya
i would never want anything bad to
happen to her
maya cares for you too
it wasn't supposed to be this way
how did we get to this
maya was freaking out she was just
trying to warn us it's like she knew
something was up see then give her a
voice give her voice a second chance
what was that we were all there me mina
and rex oh my god what was that i was so
caught up by how silly it all sounded
and i was worrying about jobs instead of
just hearing her out i'm such a mess
right now show me you're a fighter come
on get back in the ring on that horse
i'm done screwing around back and forth
rex and mina have real reasons to take
that deal
if this influencer thing doesn't work
out for me i still have options for them
this is all they have let's see why
would mean it take the deal
why wouldn't she
she's been fabricating personal
tragedies to prop up her image doesn't
that disgust you her fans are not idiots
they see right through it i don't think
they can take her suffering anymore her
story was [ __ ]
there you have it
eh you figured it out
she's turned someone else's tragedy into
a brand how despicable is that trying to
point fingers pretty hard why would she
sacrifice maya then
maya was the only one who guided her
brand in the beginning but mina's a lost
bird on her own
any backlash she got she managed to make
it worse she ended up blaming maya for
it you know
your story checks out
there you go
the deal would free her from all her
problems then go get that brat thanks
for your help
oh interesting
oh
click
oh
[Music]
uh huh
[Music]
ah
69 oh
um sorry
i'm really not up for talking right now
i don't have the space for it i'm just
feeling so torn up as it is
[Music]
no no no no
oh my god it could have been mina could
have been mina great news
[Music]
the higher ups agreed to a small field
team to apprehend the culprit
they'll do whatever it takes to prevent
the ripple man's influence from
spreading what's your process report
see
everyone's pointing fingers at each
other i'll be with you in just a moment
[Music]
oh hi this seems personal
what uh
is the deal here
i'm recording this as proof
i've been hearing it for weeks every
night
you're gonna hear it too
don't put that curse on me don't make me
hear this
why would you want me to hear this
you hear that right i'm hearing
something
i'm not crazy
stop
stop
i can't i'm from the future and i can't
affect the past
i am uh incapable of changing my current
distance to you
[Music]
okay gonna scan this
seeing things captain
my barely caught a strange phenomena on
camera oh did maya
did my
did maya indeed
mean it is silva only creative souls
will understand what it takes to turn
pain into art i don't care what people
say about me
stays true to my art
what's your take on people who think
you're commodifying trauma
commodifying trauma
what i mean is some people say you're
glamorizing tragedy
that you're selling sadness not music
like
i'm just singing about my life
and most of it sucked
music's the only way for me to deal with
it
and like
that's what we do as artists we turn our
experiences
into art
yeah so if i was thinking about this and
why it would be mina it would be okay
here's someone who literally used
someone else's death to
find success
so
an opportunity where someone you
actually know dies and also you get a
sweet deal out of it would be a win-win
for mina
i had to say and it would probably be a
bit of a win-win you know
that's all i'm saying
wow
mina's such a gas lighter
acting all innocent and smiles in front
of you and when you least suspect it she
just grabs what she needs
well her disguise isn't fooling anyone
now
i'm gonna put her under the spotlight
and expose her for the two-faced rat she
is uh well i don't know if that's your
job to do that i don't know if you
should be telling the police about that
either oh i can't talk to rex really
weird i probably already have all the
clues i need progress report is um
everyone's pointing fingers at each
other
this is turning out to be quite messy
any theories as to who's our perp
let's see
i feel like we're missing something big
are you getting this from those kids
they've covered up maya's death and
conspired with an evil entity that's the
long and the short of it
the only thing we're missing is our last
suspect's statements i still think we're
getting it wrong
no there's something more here
if you keep listening to those fakers
you're gonna jet paradise our case get
back on track that's an order this team
they gave me
if we screw this case up they'll be
taking me in instead
and if they dig deeper and detain you
two there'll be no one left to pursue
the simulacra why would they dig deeper
and detain me why would they do that
something's going on here
something weird living in his shadow was
suffocating my brother was better at me
than everything school sports social
life even our shared chimera channel
everything came to him naturally it was
an unspoken competition and everyone
questioned why i wasn't on the same
level how is he better than you if he's
younger living in his shadow was
suffocating taking the deal changed me
it was the push i needed to start living
for myself and find my own identity
through his demise
discovered missing chat okay what is
this
um price of influence maya bribing for
contact info um what would that be
right here contact bribe well
[Music]
oh
adam dupont shared an article that
explains the origin of the ripple man
and asked mai to end its reign if she
can when
adam dupont this is maya crane sorry for
the sudden messages i literally had to
bribe someone for your contact it was
hot tea oh i remember
emily told me about you and the ripple
man i need to know if you used trm or
took its deal so you caught up in trm
too huh yes i'm sorry to dump this all
on you seeing things hearing things i
have no idea what to do i am so scared
you two you do realize what it means by
sacrifice right
it's really spreading
but i think i found something while i
was away
an interview with charlie astor and the
origin of the ripple man
even [ __ ] toasters are online these
days not like even [ __ ] there's a
website dedicated to just [ __ ]
toasters abruptly disappeared from the
public eye deleted all social media two
years later he seems eager to share a
story
huh
his series on camera called ripples the
series focused on social media
experiments that served as commentaries
for of online trends and behaviors the
name itself is a reference to the
so-called ripple effect ripple's classic
hits include setting up a fake chimera
influencer account that managed to score
dozens of million dollar endorsement
contracts creating a fake rags-to-riches
persona that enthralled thousands before
he outed himself and a fake news
campaign where he convinced a shockingly
large number of people that the small
town of wyfield did not exist astor's
experiments became darker instigating
fights among the homeless baiting trolls
on the notorious seven elite forums and
mounting campaigns to cancel fellow
influencers he found morally
objectionable or disagreed with then
came the infamous chimericon live stream
in december 2015 which reached 200
million views before being scrubbed off
the web therefore it didn't actually get
scrubbed off the web now did it okay who
is the ripple man
a god i invoked it what okay you know
actually no not what i believe this okay
where's where the blackouts couldn't
remember anything so how did he beat a
god cutting off its supply of power
literally i found that bastard's
weakness because i figured that thing
moves through signals transmissions i
even had a signal jammer as a backup
just in case makeshift ritual like a
totem just as he was about to hit delete
he throws suddenly feeling the presence
besides him it felt like i was getting
choked from me inside he looked
possessed i could feel it too astor
refused to leave the cabin jamie packed
up promising influencer's career was
just another person cracking whatever
you think of astr story i believe that
he truly believes it he appears haunted
by the experience and a shell of his
former self at least in this remote
place he seems to have found something
that fans had never given him peace okay
don't contact me
interesting what about you what's going
to happen to you same as emily i guess a
fake shell of myself if i find that
totem i can help you too please don't
contact me i can't guarantee that it'll
still be me but do what you have to help
your friends save yourself blocked
okay interesting and i still can't talk
to rex can i
okay
i'm only interested in the truce
then be prepared because the truth is
often ugly and uncomfortable
one more to go
wrap it up and let me know
i've been working cases for over 35
years and let me tell you none of it has
prepared me for this okay
truth is
i don't even know if i can handle
another case like this
i just want you to understand the
gravity of what we're doing here
it needs to carry on beyond me beyond us
think about that you're what you're
saying is you need there to be people
who put their eyes on this beyond us all
that's not what you're saying i believe
that's what you're saying
okay
special privileges of dupe are currently
being reviewed all ongoing dupe
investigations will be placed directly
under hq until further notice request
for temporary personnel has been granted
for 24 hours field team delta is now
under dupe command
those seem uh
those seem contradictory statements rexy
man
i question the legality of your
operations nah i'm surprised that people
still fall for this
hi
hi you i'm a baby member only
delete an hour i'll sue you into
oblivion i think you will be the one
getting sued
are you threatening me
i'm literally a police
officer
okay okay okay it was a stupid and drive
scheme all right
but come on people just want the
opportun partner image without doing any
of the work so i thought i'd give the
people what they want you know so you're
just out for a quick book
no
kinda maybe
again before you bring out the violins
for those peeps
that lot would sell their grandmas for a
new car you're really going to piddle
people like that piddle you're going to
pill them are you going to put all those
people are you going to piddle those
people yeah so yeah i get some flack for
it but some of them actually got off
their asses and did something with their
lives oh why do i have none of these why
do i have none of these must be hard
dealing with the backlash
why do i have none of those that's weird
i tried to make it right best i could
did i miss some stuff
but it can get out of hand sometimes i
knew the risks i knew there is i got to
go big to show people that i'm killing
it but maybe that was riskier than i
thought i'm a pro i deal with failure on
my own terms i have it all planned out
you are very well prepared apparently
i told you
i'll plan out
whoa
hey
what's up just another day
why do they always stick me with these
idiots i swear
you of all people you've been doing this
too long
what just because i take the weirdo
cases everybody's gonna work against me
stick me with the losers
oh come on not another one
i had no intention of hurting maya or
anyone else i don't need some lame ass
spoopy ripple thing
mina thinks you did
god meena
you probably spooked mina so much that
she's blabbing all sorts of [ __ ] about
us you're just like my haters just
riling people up she willingly gave you
me this i knew i shouldn't have let her
in turn for me that sly witch gotta say
i'm impressed she fooled a lot of people
now she's playing you too
weak defense
that girl spins stories 24 7 because
she's a total attention here
that she took the deal just for the
drama even if it meant killing maya
maya was her hero true
but we outgrow our heroes eventually
mina wants fame real bad
looks like she got proactive for once to
get what she wants i knew she was acting
weirdly that night
what makes you think that
one minute she's all oh my god maya i'm
so sad and suddenly she was all
oh my god someone did this oh my god who
did this it was like she was deciding
how to best act sympathetic those girls
are
are all appearances and no substance
faker than three dollar bills probably
that's why they couldn't cope with the
hate
why would arya take the deal
she's all about being glamorous and
showing off how in demand she is her
camera feed is so fake because she's
insecure af that deal would help her get
the prestige you want so badly
she did lie about her brand endorsement
oh yeah that whole alluring gig
saw how she tried to spin it around too
what a hypocrite
you know i've seen her just tear down
other influencers because they dared to
be more popular than her she will
eliminate anything or anyone if they get
in her way
what about mina
how the hell did she get so popular
after pissing people off with her lies
people were really dragging her out and
[ __ ] and then suddenly right after we
get that deal thing
she gets a record deal we get that deal
thing she did lie about her tragedies
yeah so you know
and people wised up to it
her fans caught on to her goth shtick
that should have ended her career
no way she bounced back from that
without some extra help you know what i
mean i don't actually actually maybe i
do she's not capable of sacrificing maya
ah she might be i don't know if she
would have the guts though you're right
something's fishy
mean is just desperate to live live or
sad artistry i think she'll sacrifice
anything or anyone to make that reality
uh real
let's see if you're right let's see
let's see if you're right even though i
just said you're right ah many of you
figured it out already
is rex going to get arrested
i don't want maya's death to be in vain
you sure you've told me everything
yes
why are you talking to me like i did
something wrong what else did the others
say about me
i think i think i want to clear this all
out in the open
are you trying to blame me for
everything oh oh
here we go
come off it meena we know you took the
deal yeah stop acting it's already
getting old i didn't do it
you know i'll never harm maya
you're both just against me because i'm
the only one who cared about her
well the plot just thickens
what are you trying to say
that you didn't do this come on she's
just pulling her emo shtick
i should have seen the signs
all of you only think about yourselves
uh that's rich considering you summoned
a demon that killed the maya
you signed up for the service too
we all we know our limits mina you're
way out of control right now
why are we still talking can we like
contain her or something if that's what
you all think
i'm gonna start acting like the person
you want me to be
what does that mean what does that mean
what do you what do you uh what do you
what do you mean what do you mean this
is how everyone treats me oh so i'm
gonna prove them right
i just took the ripple man's deal
i hope you're all happy now
whoa
god finally she's telling the truth what
do you mean just
do it well this is going to be
interesting
wait no do it i should have said do it i
should have said do it
something's off about this
what if we're wrong
uh shouldn't we do something to stop her
she might come after us
i'll handle this we have a special team
in place for just this occasion
detective morillo you got something you
need to know send the team for mina
my god did you solve it are you sure
you're right
no room for mistakes here mina made the
deal but also that probably means that
you need to uh go send people to rex and
arya because they're probably going to
get rippled if you know what i mean are
you still on the line with them the
phone is acting up
is it broken
no not quite
the phone is the key to everything don't
break it
now please get me up to speed
i need to know to expect when we bust
down that door
uh
oh
no
oh
i did not crack it oh oh boy
don't look at me like that come on what
are you gonna be like
what what's your problem what's your
what are you looking at
ah
[Music]
oh no
oh no
ah
it was
oh
i guess
[Music]
so really i guess the truth is that it
was maya that took the deal and that's
the real problem there or whatever
but i don't really benefit you very much
but i guess that's a whole concept right
you don't really get benefit
that you can enjoy because you're the
one taken by the horrible ripple man
or ripple woman but that's what those
cuts are on the face are all about they
tear you
mina mina
ah okay
but like better
well you know we're like ripple man
our beings are like intertwined or
something
you two may like join us
uh
no thanks
but we are already tethered
you are so close you're so like close
maya took the deal too maya tried to
stop
why are you doing this we seek
connections to this
the detective
he led you astray yes
you can't fix it
i'm not falling for your deal
i'm listening
a simple choice how you will shape this
world
when you can alter reality as it is
perceived by others
you can make them seem
whatever you wish
[Music]
ah
solving a case doesn't just end with
pointing a finger at the perp where the
hell are you
oh you know
i think i'm experiencing some obscure
phenomena
what
you better not be pulling my leg i'm
pulling your leg in 19 different
dimensions right now are you with the
simulacrum i'm fine but you need to act
now
the team and i are almost at the scene
so we are right about the perp
it's more complicated than that
but i need a straight answer
there are no this case is either going
to make or break dupe dude this case is
either going to make or break the world
the team i have here best guys on the
force if we're wrong about this they'll
be taking me in instead see that doesn't
make any sense why would they do that
and if dupe is dissolved there'll be no
one left to look into these creatures
what will happen to you why would they
take you in that doesn't make any sense
misconduct charges getting fired
possible jail time it doesn't matter i
can't let all the work i put into dupe
just end the truth needs to be exposed
but please tell me we got this right you
were right mina killed maya well we made
a mistake none of them caused maya's
death i mean that is true yeah
what how is that possible
mean only took the deal moments ago maya
took the deal that's what and that's
what killed her
oh god
it was so obvious why didn't i see that
i don't know i kind of guessed it we got
it all wrong what have i done
it's not your fault
i take full responsibility well it
actually is your fault but i'll take
responsibility because i'm kind of in a
void so i'm probably already dead
i did the very thing i warned you
against i misled you my pig-headedness
killed this case and gave the ripple man
another victim don't give up now
listen
it's me from your future or past or
something like that
now i push so hard for my version of the
truth they're not going to cut me any
slack now maybe i deserve to be locked
up for the endangerment of an innocence
maya deserves justice
it was the right thing to do
[Music]
your concept of right and wrong
that's what makes me a better influencer
be buried under the power of my
followers
it was worth it
is not the only one
[Music]
well actually no i
i'm all about the whole changing thing
this isn't the end
there is no end
ah but actually authenticity is so
precious to your
everything has to end and everything has
to begin
boom
everything has to end and everything
has to begin
it's super effective
field team delta please detain detective
merlot and escort him back to hq for
processing
well i mean
all's well that ends well right
yeah that's just what i need
hi what are you doing here
come to see my career meet it's gruesome
and i don't know how i got out
what now you feel bad no
we both know you think i'm some old
useless doddering crackpot yeah
but you know damn well as i do i'm a
great cop
we were so close
until you cocked everything up
yeah we could have saved them uh-huh
you know why i was pushing you so hard
on this
it was my only lead for so many victims
[Music]
something bad is coming our way
i can feel it in my bones
your old old crackpot
i can stop it you were
forget it
just leave okay
goodbye
i guess you tried your best hey
i did
too bad it wasn't good enough
you know this is kind of like the me
strategy in space of trying to make you
feel really bad about your decisions
but honestly i don't feel bad at all um
because to be perfectly honest ooh mina
became a star
i think
because to be perfectly honest i don't
feel bad about any of that uh
because i
the whole police thing was just really
confusing like why were they going after
him like how dare you try to and then me
saying like we were wrong from the
beginning which was true
it's just like
whatever anyway that was very fun i like
this style i mean i could i could make
some critiques here and there about like
the spook factor wasn't present it was
more it was more just like kind of like
wandering than it was actually getting
the the immersive part of it but the
exploring was part of the fun i did like
it when it was the fun moments all that
aside it was very ambiguous what the
evil was i feel like they could have
done a lot more for that uh but still it
was fun like you know i don't want to
pick it apart too much because i did
like it i feel like it was just like a
little too much hunting um and not
enough uh actual like experiential stuff
i feel like um the things that were
going on with feedvid kind of like lead
me to believe that there is still a lot
of hope for this kind of form factor
where you're experiencing someone else's
uh life whether in the past or in the
future or present and it's just like
yeah it's it's super cool so i i did
like that i'm gonna see if there's
anything at the end of the credits but
uh i i enjoyed that very much and i
imagine i wonder if the whole story kind
of changes probably not to an extensive
degree but i wonder if it changes if you
don't pick the hard-boiled detective
route and what that would make uh like
how that would change it but still
very good i did like it
oh oh
oh no
mina
you stitch your face back together
okay
ah
whoa
look at that
whoa i what
whoa oh
dude
[Music]
nothing
that's how many different things there
are
[Music]
no what what
[Music]
i did not realize there were that many
things
weird
so it could have been any of these any
of them would have been correct that's
fascinating i did not know it was that
in depth i didn't know that there were
that many choices very fun very fun
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
if you want to play for yourself
apparently there is a lot of stuff to do
a lot of ways this can go link's in the
description thank you uh if you want to
check out in space with markiplier which
i've talked about a lot you can check
that out also in the description below
or the end cards of this video or the i
card whatever that is there
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you